and
he's also making tyson ranch sauce
coming soon
i really don't think that's so but tyson
ranch sauce is coming
have you tasted the tyson ranch no it's
like
great great poop hot sauce is up
grapefruit
black people great poop tabasco [ __ ]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of success we're going to talk about
that too
of hot boxing i'm evan britton i'm mike
tyson
mike we got a great guest awesome game
we got the man d-ray davis in here
yeah look i'm gonna look down the room
for a change
man i'm good man i'm comfortable man i
haven't seen you [ __ ] um
hip-hop squares and [ __ ] yeah thanks man
i appreciate it i actually um
was watching you i watched your hbo
special and i was like this is
ingenious yours my two favorites are
yours and um john i want to mess up his
last name i want to [ __ ]
up uh leguizano yeah yeah awesome his
was yeah i like i like just the
the way it was like how you know you
bring your own light to it your own
conversation and
with no interruptions and just the way
it was so
he really talented brother yeah
hopefully i'll drop some [ __ ] like that
it's awesome you could so
am i right are you 50 years old i'm the
hell not
no way there's no way i'm not man but i
don't know who changed
my age i think it's an ex-girlfriend
somebody did somebody did but
somebody did it pay attention
to everything going on with your your
your [ __ ] like your media
i don't pay attention to that stuff and
then i didn't know where i was i was 51.
so you saw that too so somebody make
that up now people wishing me [ __ ]
happy birthday on august 5th 1968 i was
like
that's my and my no my birthday's
february 26th but my grandfather's
birthday is august 5th so i thought
maybe
we ain't got the same name or nothing i
don't know how i got
i got weird i got about a decade before
i get to that but it's good
okay i mean uh it's you look at that 10
years right i say right okay
yeah yeah yeah i didn't do good math
five years of high school i ain't really
that's that's what it is it's hip-hop
squares hollywood squish what is that
thing what's the name
hip-hop squad man ice cube just uh
jumped on board and flipped it to
they tried to come out with a long time
ago on
mtv2 they tried to do hip-hop squares
and i was one of the squares on that end
but they didn't have the budget to match
what the idea was you know what i'm
saying sometimes you got a great idea
and the budget don't you know what i
mean it's like it's like the dope boy on
the corner you got to come out of your
own pocket yeah the dope boy on the
corner he like man i wish
i want to go get all the keys and all
but at the time ain't right so that's
what it was they had
they had a product but didn't have the
right resources but then when cube came
along
vh1 was ready for it so it's like the
old hollywood squares back and robin
when you were
told whoopi goldberg was on there just a
lot of uh
celebs and people who think they celebs
you know that's there's a lot of that
going on right now but uh there's a lot
of celebs
a lot of influencers a lot of people
doing god knows what but it's popping
man
it it went off i was happy to be hosting
i was gonna tell you that i know how to
read
[ __ ] it's a great gig because i didn't
know i know how to read that good
and there they were without getting from
that teleprompter i was like oh this is
nice i can
thank a teacher ah that's amazing
you gotta get on there man yeah mike
should definitely be
i'm sure we would have to shoot it over
here on the ranch at the ranch
where are we mike as long as mike can
have some weeds what are we at where
else
el segundo q-tip left his wallet
yes a long time that's right it was far
back to el segundo right i kind of know
i kind of got a feeling why y'all way
out here
tell me because the airport right there
and
okay you got a lot of white people here
they want be close to the airport in
case something jump off i see
all the private planes over there just
get the hell out of here
got it great for business everybody's
right here hey get out of here
yeah easy and easy out
uh i go live let me get this out of the
way i'm excited man many times i've met
you and seen you or whatever
i'm a fan um i don't know how to put it
in in the proper words without sounding
like a lame
lame [ __ ] but i um i had five mike
tyson t-shirts and i chose the wu tang
because i was like i'm gonna look super
lame
if i wear that's like when being next to
mine in the club and you got that jersey
on
like a basketball player football player
but um
i'm i'm a real fan man i like the way
you uh just marketed everything and it's
real hard brandon down to the cartoon
everything i watch i'm not making up
[ __ ] i watch this [ __ ] i don't have to
thank a lot of nobody on makeup [ __ ]
i'm like yo this is it's epic it's what
you want to do you want to
control all bits and pieces of your
brand so i always i just realized in
life that um
my thoughts are my reality you know
and whatever i thought in my mind that i
wanted to do i i
i pretty much accomplished it i see it
looking
another funny thing about exhibit story
i was uh this is back did you have him
on squares
no exception when he feel like you know
he had a little ranch too he disappeared
yeah exhibit will disappear go buy three
rolls royces and disappear
drive him separate i think he rolls in
in a lambo or something like
that he's rolling pretty hard yeah he's
been since jump start i was in a club
and um
i remember i i just got from chicago i
had to be like 20 years old and i was in
a club out here
and exhibit songs uh uh
that's when the album came out 40 days
40 nights and he had that record like
and i i was a deep hip-hop i loved i
loved like real hip hop and he was from
he was out here but his vibe was like
straight
new york mixed with the blender he was
like it's about players pimps
ballers busters slipping these studs
i saw the video he's walking to get
[ __ ] milk or something
and everything's exploding behind him
and i was like this is crazy so i walked
past um him at the club and i tapped my
child's mother i said yo
[ __ ] that's exhibit and she said
who i said the dude i showed you the rap
video that's the [ __ ] the first rapper i
was singing like that i was like yo
that's the [ __ ]
is it [ __ ] [ __ ] and she's like oh you
should say someone's like nah i know
lame [ __ ] like that so i walked to the
bar and stood next to him i was like i
tried to play it i was like yeah you uh
exhibit yeah uh like they played and i
said i'm gonna
come to my comedy show on monday and he
was like yeah don't talk about my voice
though
everybody's cracking my voice yeah but
we ended up becoming good friends man
and through the years like yeah like
like we used to go about a house the
first i've never been to a crab boil
although i'm
i'm allergic to shellfish i still looked
at it i looked at the broil whatever
looked good
uh he taught me how to boil but at the
time the situations around him had
taught i learned how to boil
uh uh artichoke i've never done that and
i still do that to this day this
many years later he i went to the studio
i put i did like
uh on this mixtape i um did like a hook
for it
like broke because i would right hooks
all the time what i worked with
differently i worked with eric serving
all that so he took like
three or four of my hooks and and i was
able to you know get my
my writer credit up it's just it was
dope though hell yeah dude have you
stories
have you done a lot of music writing
yeah a whole lot
mostly for me but um i've always been
involved in music since the beginning
like
where did you started from where you
come from come from chicago man
yeah how did you get how did you get
from chicago to the sunny city
[ __ ] i was uh my uncle was a bartender
at a comedy club and um
he the uncle that taught me how to i was
uh dabbling back in the day with just
with
cannabis back in the day dabbling a
little bit and uh
i was getting yeah i was getting to the
point where it was it was real
comfortable for me but i would go see
him
at a comedy club and he was the bigger
guy
with the production of that and uh i
sent him comedian on stage i never seen
comedy for my life never not one time
and i saw a comic on stage and i was
like yo this that [ __ ] we be doing just
roasting each other
i could do this in my uncle like man if
you don't get your ass back here like
you ain't supposed to be in the club
right he like come back here
and then i told talked to the uh the
host his name was damon williams
and i said how you get on stage you said
well we have sunday nights we got open
mic night
that's how i want to go up like when i
was like next sunday i know i said it
was that night i said
he said tonight he said nah they ain't
had work bro you gotta you ain't never
been on stage i was like i want to go up
so i was working at a place called the
same time we're in a place called
ameritech i don't remember that i was a
4-1-1 operator
like david sitting in state like
answering the phone and one of
damon williams cousin's wives this
ghetto was that my sound
worked there and i said yo you know
damon williams i said i asked him when i
got on stage
and he was like no i got to get to no
comment basically they made the call so
i went up that next week
and i had a notebook of jokes and [ __ ] i
tried to try to do them jokes and people
were like oh what the [ __ ]
what's what man get up like and it was
two people really heckling me and it was
men at large you remember that group
yeah they're too big i lived in
cleveland i know i'm from cleveland
i'm sorry i don't know
did he yeah i didn't know that but it
was it was the [ __ ] that won um
the one that won on apollo him and he
was a new one and he was with the other
guy but it was him and david or whatever
can't think his name geronimo james i
can't think of any names i haven't
talked to him
from cleveland okay yeah so men at large
and i started roasting the hell out of
them and they said
you need to be funny and i said y'all
wish these like go back to your book of
jokes and i was like y'all wish this was
a menu [ __ ]
and i did 13 minutes my first time on
stage and everybody's looking like
[ __ ] he might have it so within how old
were you
19. wow so within six months
i had uh i got in the middle of a comedy
series within six months i took second
place in that [ __ ]
i kept i kind of had a little you know
little mike tyson spark man i ain't
gonna lie to you
if a comedy not not compared to the
boxing a little bit yeah
my mom would know the background
everything but getting into it i was
right off the bat like that guy
yeah like i was just i'm just hitting
everything hit and winning like man how
are you doing
how much courage yeah so much but they
told me much courage they were always
telling about all the people that
because i was still you know
like i would go on stage and rap and
[ __ ] back then like a [ __ ] dude
and since i was little i was doing like
trying to jump on karaoke mics and
the founding union i tried to wrap
something or do something with
those shows in the basement yeah i used
to pin up the [ __ ]
curtain and do commercials for my mama
and [ __ ] just to
you know just to just do something i
don't know just do something plus you
know
and it was a lot of us too so like
kid-wise you gotta always
out entertaining [ __ ] other
brothers and sisters yeah man
my dad got down okay my dad got down all
the kids they had to be around each
other regardless was different moms are
not that's just how tony was
i had to be you got to be around i got
to be at it
and then um it just took off man six
months and a year later i had a deal and
all that it was it was fast
wow it was fast before i then i was like
no i'm just gonna act and that's when
you hit the wall like [ __ ] you better
do something different
than just act i had to you know touring
is important with with comics if any
young comic watching stay working stay
working on your craft and stay working
doing it
cause that's how uh like kevin hart you
know he was out doing the work
yeah we was roommates and he was out
doing the work he was like i'm doing
these comedy clubs and i always believe
we need to get discouraged then huh
doing this [ __ ]
well mine was i always wanted to own the
stuff like i watched
i watched the dude at the door taking
the money and i watched it he paid the
comedians and i was like i want to own
[ __ ] so
within that same year uh the year after
that i actually bought a comedy club
it was kind of thought i was going so i
bought into the comedy club 20 years old
riddles at 20 i was going to 21 then but
i had got my deal too
so i took my little disney money i
looked into that and i was booking
comedians and i was booking tours i
booked everybody from the moniques to
the
uh well not cedric cedric i had him come
through but i've paid
i paid more comics than [ __ ] have ever
paid me i've always wanted to be on that
side of the business
like and even look like my my pups is
here but her
her other client lorell who's blowing up
everywhere yeah
he took over the comic club for me like
he would host while i was going to la
doing saying he'd been he was building
and getting stronger but
my whole thing was i do the tour i pay
everybody myself
robin harris i did not i think robin was
gone by the time i got back
but i heard he was he a lot of people
said the length of time i spent on stage
when i'm just riffing he he had that
like he had he just would just talk
the closest thing to him was the bernie
man that's the that's the closest man
both of those guys man he was beautiful
robin harris oh i love him so much
i always tell people if they had the
opportunities that the comics have now
people be in trouble man like rob
imagine robin harris with a
netflix special for bernie who barney
never got
to drop that soul
robin harris is just um it's so
weird if anybody came to see robin house
they wouldn't all the celebrities would
sit in the back nobody would be in the
front
cause they just you can't feel it on top
watch him until you have to be there
you got to see him on television his
beauty his excellence don't come out on
television
whoa he was a master everybody was
sitting there
everybody take the outfit petrified and
they frail the girls are afraid to go to
the bathroom
yes you'll say yourself yes terrified
yeah that's terrifying well that's so
interesting man you just
you just hit it it was like a switch
went on for you
yeah i'll say that what were you doing
as a kid i mean because obviously you
didn't start writing that week
you've been writing no but i always i
would
i'm i guess a fast study with things
like that man when they when it comes to
hustling like gang
yes yeah you're a street kid yeah yeah i
was on a game
so were you always a guy who was super
smart
again no i was the guy that i'd be like
even when i was serving i'd always say
it was somebody above me
who people would like so nobody would
come like try to rob me
i would always say yo it's my uncle's
[ __ ] or
i was i know i was dropping names of
people i didn't even talk to
i'm like yo this big this big herb [ __ ]
and they've been like yo for real
reminds me a little bit of l.a because
you know it's
very few guys you can see as well i mean
like one guy
you know that you can see walk up the
street and you could say hey i need a
crew and
really i'll be back a woman and he can
come bring 100 guys
and that's just so simple it's just so
many gangs yeah man
it was the weird part was more
simplistic because
i felt i i always even even in the game
like i'm telling one thing i never did
gang and i've never jumped nobody in my
entire life when i heard it was coming
up
or situations like that i didn't take
part in i never i loved the one-on-ones
i loved the
but i also [ __ ] did different shows i
also went to the rec center i was
still in the game my mom was like
knowing i was in the game but you
couldn't you better go to the [ __ ]
rec center i still did
dancing i still did the ballet [ __ ] i
still did grappling
all like all the time you know what i
mean but so i always thought that side
of it i was more on the organizational
side like i want
if we gonna squad we gonna squab y'all
squad but i don't like like i
never all of a sudden this stuff i seen
around me the shootings the everything i
yeah couldn't do it i didn't lie i
didn't fake some shootouts
i never even fired i'm telling everybody
now
everybody thought i was shooting out and
never i was hey my childhood friends i
met we had we met by fighting each other
yep my best friend larry met at the park
10 years old
friends friends because you know what
kind of worries you got around you
yeah you don't even you don't know that
until it happened because other than
that you got
dudes around you just just around you
know you never know what until something
come up but you if you've been into it
this person has seen that or met that
person
even people i didn't fight but somebody
was fighting for me i've i've had
friends like that
like i'm trying to go somewhere and they
like you know this is and you can just
feel that energy for you like
when i had no movies out here like this
dude gonna be big dude
and you feel like whoa like this dude
yeah he can feel your energy like you
know it's so crazy like
off the subject for it's a second um you
know like most people
almost black people so minorities and
puerto ricans and all that stuff
you know we didn't even know we had jobs
we didn't have much money physical money
in the 60s
very few black people had a bank account
like let's say the 50s and stuff
we're just kind of kind of scared of the
bank account stuff i remember
being raised how my grandfather was a
lot of money out of mattress money
mm-hmm
you know what i mean you wouldn't
holiday died with 70 cent in her bank
account but like 300 bucks on her
personal
or something like that you know i mean
yeah they think you were right they kept
how much
they kept money on that person more than
the bank yeah yeah 70 cent in the bank
but like 300 bucks i think was on a
personal or something like that more
money than a person that was in the
place
white people yeah or the white people
say i'm your bank let me teach you how
to bank no i'm saying they probably did
start it like that let me teach you how
to bring
give me the money let me show you how to
bank work give me two dollars now in a
month
i'm gonna give you two dollars and two
cents so i was looking at this
no listen um at even emma i'm sorry to
go right
um so i'm watching this thing and it
goes like this it goes
um cornelius vanderville and my
rothschild both very wealthy died
wealthy so
vanderbilt left his money to his
children and so right now
there's no more millionaires they [ __ ]
all the money up
um the rothschild guy left his money to
a banking service
and where it allowed the kids to have a
certain amount of money and take a
certain amount of money out and if they
don't pay it back in
then they're off the [ __ ] list they
can't take money back no more is that
chase
no this is a rough child oh chases
rockefellers
yes sears and chase's rockefellers yeah
so i was saying
um some big bank talk i don't know none
of this [ __ ] they saying right now i'm
sitting there like i
i go to chase in back of america i don't
know who owned what though
well when i'm saying vanderbilt pretty
much gave his money to his children he
gave his money to a banking system
hand the money out you know so
interesting and the kids didn't live up
to that system they were off the system
they
can't get involved so they still have
money though huh they still got bread
then they still got money the
rothschilds so i think they cut them
really a boom
they have nothing else to bring to
because they have to bring something to
the system
they're not bringing something to the
system and bringing back the money to
the system they don't
they don't pay back then they're taking
from the system and not just one person
is bigger than the whole [ __ ] system
somebody have to be lost in the family
yeah yeah i wish i could set up a system
like that with my daughter but now
i understand that system though it's
just working off of no feeling this is
objective it's very successful it will
work
yeah if it's objective yeah no that
makes sense so i gave it to my kids i
had my feelings don't know i better give
it to my kids i love them so much i want
them to be happy like i was happy
and you know i really pampered them all
day like they know how to fight and be
competitive for this money so they lose
it all
pretty much you don't have the thought
process like that i had a conversation
with my daughter all the time i'm like i
paid off
i just paid off her whole like uh uh
tuition for the first semester's pace
she went down to gremlin just last week
i just paid it off and i got a text
thanks for paying my tuition
like [ __ ] unless i don't want to talk
to you about gratitude
this is all right okay don't be listen
all right all right
what i'm saying and that's saying don't
know it mr tyson i'm saying that same
in that same light of what you're saying
though when you're saying you want to
give them something
when you don't have you're like i didn't
i didn't have and you know how it felt
kind of and some some feelings you don't
want them to have like down to your
daughter being heartbroken so
or but we we play both sides like on one
one note i blew i'll go take 20 20 30
grand i didn't put that on 12 before at
the casino
you know what i'm saying then i have an
auntie that need a car and i'm like
but in my mind i just did what was right
with my money because i took the gamble
because i'm the person that
got it yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah so maybe i need if i set that
system up for myself
if i don't bring something to the table
i take it from me i don't know huh maybe
i'm making no sense maybe you don't know
that's accountability
that's self-accountability right maybe
i'm um taking in some of which i spoke
but you gotta learn these things just
[ __ ]
know it i'm realizing you know gratitude
that's
one gratitude now you do but what do you
just
know it innately it's not intuitive no
no like sometimes i may see somebody
that i love or care about someone's
opening the door for them they just walk
through the door
and i have to hey [ __ ] say thank you
yeah i know i hate that i
hate that [ __ ] but you gotta deep on
that i'm happy on that too
[ __ ] out in public in front of all
these white people like that but the
fact is
it's just very important to me for my
mother and my father is very important
yes ma'am no sir yeah very important we
were very poor but that was very
important all day i agree
all day bump it's 1000 percent i said if
you want to understand
where you can get smackdown yeah yeah
absolutely i said if you want to
understand want to see how i feel of
not it's a world of non-gratitude go to
the club and don't have a drink at all
and just stand there
and see how people bump into you and
count how many people say
excuse me drunk or not because it's a
reflex
because me drunk or not i'm always
excuse me i can absolutely i say excuse
me when i'm alone if i fart by myself in
the house
i said excuse me the case god listening
that's just how i am excuse me like
pardon me or anything you know
it's just and that translates to the
other stuff you're talking about but i
and i never understood that either but i
did it because i would get my ass beat
so i just always did it but always
people
liked me for being that way even people
who considered
not nice people dislike me for being
there they were able to be that way
you know i realized in life how it
really i took me a
long way in life and then i realized the
reason why my mother and father was like
that because
the system that they lived in humbled
them and so i guess in return they had
to humble me
innately but that's to prevent me from
what she experienced it was her father
my father experienced
i still don't though because then when
you when you're a polite person like
that or to the point where we know we're
being polite
then when you step outside of that you
know that you're in the right
you know when you're in the right like
you said hey excuse me i look brother i
try to tell you excuse me four times
exactly now you know that you know when
we snow
so whatever i'm about to do to you you
had it coming
you know you know i don't know if you
know the comedian scrancho do you know
scratch it look crazy he's a wife
yo this [ __ ] he told me one time he
told me one time he said
he said i used to feel bad about beating
people up he said now
he said dear because he's old he's like
i'm old he said when i hit people now i
feel like i'm helping god because i'm
i'm i'm knocking the demon out of them
yeah
he said there's a demon it's a good way
to look at it because he's a real nice
guy he said when he so when he come do
something he said there was a demon in
him but he also the guy who said
by the way i don't wanna he also said
this that was in jesus
he only know remember saying [ __ ] like
this he said i love the lord but the
devil has got some [ __ ]
i was like wow so
i balanced and tried to listen to him
but still hearing that at the same time
but he said
he knocked the demon out of people man
look at [ __ ] too yeah
you know he got in there all he brought
him in we is true true
we define him as that he don't call him
up but that's what we define him but he
got him here for us
yeah okay guy got something to do it's
just a church sometimes it's hard to
talk him right out of the out of the
church to go straight to the crib you
know
well i'm sorry oh my god
god invented that word it's in our mind
we can never stop even when we say them
in the closed doors he know he said he's
all seen he's all hearing he knows
everything about us when we jerk off
whatever we do in private that we don't
want nobody to know he sees
us he sees them you know um
he said he sees it wow he knows
amen when you get up to heaven god's
looking hey brother
wipe your hands
white white has another cloud over there
yeah
um what was it that should be part of
heaven though
you can't do if you can't do that in
heaven i mean i just think it's it's all
there
it's all i'm sorry i'm not being
blasphemous i'm saying i just think
like you said god knows god grows i
think back in the day the things he was
mad about
i don't think he'd get as mad now but
listen you really
if we really believe in god you know um
man put so much guilt in us and we have
gifts in our country
that's five years ago oh my god god's
gonna get back and
with god there's no good or bad there's
no time no space
there's no judgment your love
how could i expect something that i just
created out of dust
to be able to [ __ ] resist temptation
is his mind you his for his testing this
is all the tests
and we all going to fail but we're going
to learn from all our failures
and become better human beings the
creatures the aliens whatever [ __ ] we
are
i like aliens i'll be that
probably yeah to somebody yeah
to people in another dimension yeah
we're aliens so that's fair
yeah we're all one
aliens dirt bugs ants creatures
trees everything stars rocks we all won
all everything it's all one thing
um before we go much deeper
what was it do you think about
the way you thought about what you
wanted to do with your life
that gave you that
idea of i want to control and own the
[ __ ] that i'm doing
and because i mean not many young kids
you're you're just trying to like figure
it out
at that point yeah my i was just into my
ego i didn't want to hurt
[ __ ] and he's going to be it for that
moment you know you want to possess
that putting it into my head you know
you just get a deal you're [ __ ] on
fire and the comedy
touring you know you're [ __ ] i can't
even explain because sometimes there's a
lot of trouble if you're doing all that
[ __ ]
what no i can't lie that seems like a
lot of trouble yeah
like i wanna and it feels like it until
i'm
sort of moving and i'm getting it i
wanted to be before i even knew what al
haymon was before i even knew what uh
i just i i always seen the other the
other money
you know i'm saying when i was playing
monopoly i wanted to be the banker i was
like what's the rules like who made
these rules up
i was i would i would turn cereal boxes
when i was little my mom would buy the
[ __ ] here but
i would turn everything in my room into
a bank even if i couldn't put nothing in
it
come on yeah yeah i do when i got here
they said i had a lot like my agents
like i said i won every you know you
know chris smith man
chris [ __ ] chris psycho chris
i made chris i made chris give me every
bit of every dime before i put and i i
put out
ask chris about my expenses man i paid
like a comedy club will tell me to this
day that they spent
5 000 on promotions i don't even [ __ ]
about that
i still take another 5 000 of my dollars
because i want my promotion to sound
like what i wanted to say
i don't know what you're saying about me
and yours i could hear it and get
approval but you still can't make it
sound the way i want you can't sell me
better than i can sell me
there's nobody could do that so i wanted
to be in charge of
everything i got a promotion behind
these mics a lot you do a lot of
promotions going to radius
yeah and tell and tell comics how to
promote themselves too i don't keep
i'm not secretive with it i try to dude
you gotta have your own podcast yeah
what the [ __ ] are you doing
no man that's it i love this i love the
setup i love the setup but time is
time is a lot of things and i don't even
know what the hell the age of modding
technology
think uh you you're [ __ ] in the stone
ages you got to come back all right
well we don't listen i said radio
stations we don't even go to radio
stations no more you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] and though more people know
what you're doing than a radio station
you're right
i'm taking that advice man i'm not gonna
not take it from two big [ __ ]
i'm not gonna not do it and get in
trouble now because i don't know
anything and i know this [ __ ] is you
have to have this [ __ ]
yeah but once you put your bro when
y'all have likes and [ __ ]
all these numbers of people who like you
and then your [ __ ] numbers and [ __ ]
you gotta have everything right
you ain't [ __ ] if you don't got
subscribers or whatever
you get all your fault you're right i
was watching the show the other day and
not having a [ __ ] passport
it was saying that the news was going to
be like that soon like how the news is
coming down it's going to start being
via
the the chicken think about like like
because kim kardashian got all the
followers imagine she started her own
news channel [ __ ] when she does it
people gonna go to her for the news
rather than go to
cnn because they don't dang guys cnn
ain't got as many followers as no
she do so she can come and say whatever
she wants yeah exactly
all the news i get now is through either
instagram yeah yeah twitter what's the
[ __ ] weird everything i don't watch
the news what's trending what happened
first because you know it's real because
a lot of people are right there yeah
eyewitnesses now record it and and send
it up right at that moment
it's a new [ __ ] era man i hear you
man i'm i'm on it but gotta remember i'm
still
i'm still always like with the i still
pass out flyers for my shows
i do i still i still put a certain
amount of money in that still look if if
there's a local newspaper we do
interviews every now and then because it
might be some old [ __ ] like
[ __ ]
you know what i'm gonna go check out
this dale ray davis i just never know
what would you think be the grandest way
to promote yourself
um end all be all uh
holograms coming out the phone yeah
hologram coming out the phone is crazy
you click on something to come out and
[ __ ] like
no come to my show your phone and then
one of your um [ __ ] promotions just
kind of boom
yeah all that yeah yeah that's gonna be
crazy
i'm sure it's coming it's it's already
probably already here yeah
it's already here i was on the hologram
not too long so long ago
my friend did the hologram with me i was
chilling down the chair
all right did they do a hologram of you
mike
i was i was in the hologram you were in
it yeah you see it
yeah i could sit down and touch people i
couldn't touch them but it seems like i
can touch it it's dope as hell
like that's if you want to get to the
bread like to do one show one night the
same way they do streaming like they did
wait like the
the what they just do with the miley
cyrus on black mirror
well they had it like she was a gigantic
hologram and they yeah
like do they have that going on where
you performing your show and it's
actually something people go to payday
yeah yeah a worldwide show yeah crazy
crazy
well you mentioned kevin hart earlier
and
he [ __ ] busted his ass at every
wasn't it that at every show he had like
an
email list signed up yeah but we learned
we learned a lot from jamie foxx like
james jamie
foxx did that as well yeah so i would
and and i was doing it but miles for
promotions like for
not promoting me i was trying to make
all of them jimmy smart was smart
probably just if you're looking up to
people like i have my list
jamie's top ten um
as far as like hustling and getting
stuff done yeah jamie sam jackson number
one
oh i love that number one and i've only
met him once and it was
quick and passing but just his work
ethics yeah you know dropping so many
mixtapes that's what he did
you see him in all the old movies or
whatever you see you see him go from
balding in one movie to a full afro
people to know you putting out all those
tapes yeah
right that's why i do all the movies i
do um that's pretty much the 90s and
stuff right
they're doing the stuff and like check
out what eddie murphy had to do or
richard pryor i know they have to do
you see an audience right yeah it's
brand new audience they never heard of
them
and they go and they go ahead go on
stage yeah
imagine that they never heard you or
nothing and then you have to make these
people
laugh and they did that was talent man
that was talent yeah
cause you made and that's some people at
home they're making their family
laughing like you funny enough
that's when encouragement came from just
the crib they'd be like go up there and
knock it out crazy right how could now i
think the way that you're doing
how crazy it is now you got your
instagram files you go on stage you got
a certified like
right right the comedians on stage you
heard of them i saw them before
and now back then if well when you first
go up a lot
you still it's still a test but i did
feel uh
cold places you feel it you know things
have changed you're like damn cause
sometimes you want that feeling back to
know if you're really being funny
you know what i mean cause i've stepped
on stage you know seven stages recently
people
cheering and clapping because they've
seen you do stuff and you're like damn
it's kind of cheating a little bit you
know
cheating a little bit because i want to
say some [ __ ] and know if it's really
funny rather than
just because i'm me say it and a lot of
comments get lost in that i mean i don't
want to
say i'm better than [ __ ] and what
[ __ ] i'm saying that no
but really i invite them comments out on
my show all the time on monday like come
do some new [ __ ] but
they fear they they get it yeah they
think they think they just go on stage
how about
dave chappelle oh he's great too david
go up anywhere that's what uh
he's one of the few people i couldn't
even challenge dave goes to my show all
the time he does gotta do the improv on
mondays dave will come down and just go
up and do two hours
i don't stay for all his shows all the
time because sometimes you're up there
forever yeah
really up there d-ray want me to go to
the disco
tonight i totally think i always have
respect until eddie murphy was the
greatest
and i saw this um documentary on richard
pryor
he went on stage to do a show he
bombed he [ __ ] bought he was
he he couldn't even make himself he's
nobody like everybody says what the
[ __ ] going on
he went home came back the next night
they let him go on stage again and he
[ __ ] killed the show
he wrecked them they never laughed they
were taking them out
to the hospital listen man if i did that
today they wouldn't even let me come
back they'd arrest me if i tried to come
back the next day and perform
he came back the next day and ripped him
apart did you ever see that doctor
no he said oh he's a monster nobody's in
his league
after that you'd be so depressed you
wouldn't want to go near a stage
it's what he's is he that vicious is
what he's saying you can't i'm normal
he's not a normal
yeah no no there's there's no [ __ ]
there's no comparison to the pain that
he dropped on stage because nowadays
going to go back the next day
not even 24 hours to face that pain
again no this nobody
understands the plan that could ever
match him
his nerve oh get the [ __ ] out of here
you can't
this [ __ ] when i lose a 5 he's so
[ __ ] mad be so
i'm almost paralyzed psychologically for
a week
but mike let me tell you there's some
comics man who go up
every night and bomb they still want to
go on stage they think this is the night
or this is the crowd
exactly they don't even want you to go
near that stage right but they know they
let them go up i've but i personally and
i'm i'm not saying i'm just
not being scared i'm just putting this
out there since that moment in 13
minutes
i've never i've i've had half a bad show
i've never had a bad show i've always
been i've always been able to
find because i was raised by my granddad
who's a talker in the room so i was
always able to find
somebody or something that i'm gonna
relate to that's gonna protrude energy
out
the worst show i've ever had the worst
two shows i had with both music shows
one time i only had 10 minutes of
material and met the man red man had me
open up they was doing the blackout tour
and i was out of material [ __ ] was 45
minutes late
and the crowd was looking at me like
what's next and i was
i was all out of the what are the ladies
what are the women
everybody doing i was this close to
break dancing
and them [ __ ] finally showed up and i
was like and even then i was just like
yo what's drinking over there like still
i wouldn't let
the crowd but i also wasn't being
challenged to
to tell my story like richard was saying
how
his mother was in a in a prostitute and
then
them kind of stories you transition over
but he did give me the confidence to say
because my mother was on drugs for a
long time my mama's on crack all stuff
it did give me the confidence to to go
on stage and not be afraid
to tell them kind of stories or my wife
at the time
me getting divorced at 18 19 years old
me on stage hurt and a [ __ ] in the
audience yelled out
that's why your wife and um can't come
with my [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] and we went into voice yet and i
stopped and it was like
long the longest ten seconds evan come
back at it and i was like i was like
i was like man i said [ __ ] she didn't
win a lot of places for cheaper than
that like some forgot what it was but
but i can't lie like that wasn't a kid i
can't act like that wasn't a kidney shot
though and i remember the comics in the
back was like oh
even everybody felt it was like we were
one person everybody god damn like
probably say that [ __ ] and that
and and moments like that that you're
not afraid to drop on stage
but the worst shows i had like that show
and i died on tour with kanye
oh my god i went up there in between i
guess some for some reason rihanna
couldn't do the tournament
i never asked why i just jumped on the
tour and it was i was going up between
while i was changing the sets in the
back
at madison square garden 22 000. and i'm
up there but
in the middle what i changed between the
two people going
what's up new york in a bulls jersey
yeah man so times like that but i've
never experienced just straight up
boo uh i just won't and maybe it's good
and maybe because
maybe because it's brutal maybe because
it's a lot
like i said one one man the gift of gab
is an important thing two
people like richard and jamie and all
them
lays so much foundation for comedy that
people have a different respect for it
after they've seen
all that happen so we wouldn't
experience no kind unless you
like even def jam not the same no more
you would never go through that audience
where people just like
boo boo just straight up show time to
apollo they
do now it's bullying like if they put
you on stand you get booed like they
don't bull at the apollo no more and
they might they for a second but they
wouldn't air it because you might sue
because it might
it's just just the [ __ ] you don't go
through what i
think is good everybody needs to taste
adversity yeah
failures success yeah i think i was so
scared of the [ __ ] that that's why i
went so hard every time i think i was
like
[ __ ] this because that [ __ ] get out
quick yeah you step off stage the whole
world knows what just happened
now like you said everything d-rate just
bombed you yeah
yeah what um what do you think about
do you do you feel like comedy is a lot
different than it was
when you came into it yeah yeah yeah and
uh
it's words you can't say now it's it's
things luckily
i i started i was messing with this girl
that was on this kind of [ __ ] before
this [ __ ] was happening
huh so we beat places now she'd call you
out
now look at that whatever how's your
talk she's like don't
don't say that because that's offensive
and i'd be like and she's a
uh uh she's a real estate lawyer and
she's already like i can't say this kind
of stuff means this is
yeah 12 13 years ago and she just said
i'm like
really like that word offend what they
say no
so i was luckily prepared because if i
talk the way i talk then now even i look
at something i'll say
you can see [ __ ] you can't they can't
take [ __ ] from [ __ ]
they can't think about it they can't
imagine taking different how mad [ __ ]
would be
saying we can't say it'll be a movement
it'll be it'll be a whole nother movie
you can't have a conversation
[ __ ] [ __ ]
they got too many meanings
200 meanings yeah no no words like that
you can't get
but but trust me if somebody were to say
that they are the the main [ __ ] right
now because which they can say they come
and say i'm
i'm i'm offended by the word let's not
say it or somebody say i'm offended and
they want to start suing people
[ __ ] they're going to sue [ __ ] out
of [ __ ] and this it's [ __ ] up
you can't push nobody you can't punch
nobody that push you
this [ __ ] is crazy
and i try to tell [ __ ] all the
time but yo you about to make me offend
you
cuz i've done sets well i know i can't
be president
i don't ever be president no no i don't
be president i don't really think
you probably could stop i'm a man
because anybody can clearly be president
black
can't can't talk the way we talk and be
president somebody
[ __ ] than a white person saying that to
stop saying [ __ ]
how do you get how do you get them to
stop saying how you get a black person
really you know you don't how did
that really happen to be honest
sincerely how does that happen i'm
telling you i think i didn't get an
email
i think i didn't get an emmy reverend
yeah when it comes yes brother yes
brother and this and then when it really
ended
this [ __ ] yeah it comes out this [ __ ]
did this yeah you heard jesse jackson
did yeah when he was like they got the
[ __ ] by the walls they talked about
obama they got the [ __ ] by the ball so
i was like holy [ __ ]
but everybody no no you ain't gonna get
that out of nobody man especially
listen that word that when people wrote
books about that was that word just um
stems up so much
[ __ ] that word [ __ ] yeah but
like they say man even if they buried
the word like nwacp with someone bearing
the word even if they bury the word what
would be on the tombstone
we'll be on the headstone [ __ ] died
they hit the idea
it could still be right there so there's
no getting rid of the word
i'm comfortable with it but i know i
said i know i said it more times than
anybody on any special app on netflix
you heard it every day how many times a
day for 325 years or something like 250
years something like that
you heard it every day for hundreds
hundreds of times a day millions of
times a day
how does that stop is so brainwashed is
so unfucking
and [ __ ] thirst in my mind i sold a
[ __ ]
barometer but to to take it and reown it
or take it i just man i ain't gonna lie
to you
i never i never thought about not saying
it i just try to stop myself from saying
like on the news and [ __ ] but
i'd be like you know it is hard though
even if you're describing yourself let's
say you're saying it
suddenly i'm not you're saying it like
it's harder on [ __ ]
people get what you say then you say
it's harder on black people you sound
like you're crying
you say it's hard on [ __ ] out here
they get it
everybody get it even the white people
trying not to listen to it
get what you're saying because they
can't say that because if you say it's
hard on black people like it's hard on
everybody
but you say it's hard on [ __ ]
they can't even fight that police pull
you open you say it's cause i'm black
[ __ ] out i put all four black before
white pbs hey just call my [ __ ] huh
we're not let's not go there let's not
do that
let's not come on guy oh look man let me
just go get a ticket
it's a different it's a different thing
so is it something
you'd rather say i'll say it man i'm
the black man the white man got in
common they both hate [ __ ]
that that was told to you by a really
angry dude no no no no i mean no no
[ __ ]
i see what you're saying society he grew
up in the 50s that was the society he
grew up in
you know everybody was fighting that
certain type of black guy
everybody teamed up black people and
white people teamed up for that
particular kind of black guy to keep
them out of our circle out of our
society
huh yeah but sometimes you can make like
like like me like almost
you make fun of it man it's a fun word
it's a it's a cool word it's a serious
word it's a
like he said earlier it's like so many
descriptions of of what it is man like
uh why'd you get that song uh [ __ ]
when they got ready come on i was
hosting poppy the other thing they got
ready to come on i said fred the dj i
said before you play that let me make
this announcement
white people are watching y'all mouths i
don't give a damn if it's a song or not
you know what the music
and i was watching in front it was like
written
how hard it is not to say [ __ ] in a
song oh you know how hard it is
[ __ ] in parrot man come on man come on
jay-z do a concert jig that's my
[ __ ] white people like
[ __ ]
they in the car singing it all the time
all day so you know i mean
you're not gonna get rid of that that
word is that word is is probably obama's
still saying that
okay
[Laughter]
is it something you'd rather say less or
no
i would say uh because of my uncles and
upbringing to have been around because
of them
and and just the people i was around i
would like to say it less
for my um generation and i do say less
to the kids around me
because i am an uncle man i always say
you know like my my sisters don't talk
to their kids the way i talk to the kids
so if you if i called my nephew i said
[ __ ] what's your school doing he know
my sincerity or it make them laugh a
little bit when you're trying to say
[ __ ] let me see your poor car like you
that uncle that make them
fee they feel like they're they're your
friend because it's the one word
that i'm not you know boy boy like it's
it's the
it's the thing that makes make you the
cool uncle too like with them so
i would say less but in society as far
as my netflix special me saying it over
a hundred times
yes i wish i'd have said it less but i
also wish i'd had less tequila when i
shot that too
that damn show has something to do with
it [ __ ] count
i don't know i think it's one of the um
i don't know it's one of the words that
enslaved me i think
or i'm enslaved by it so to speak it's
just who i am
you know [ __ ]
damn but you don't know you know what
though no no no black people call
everything [ __ ] too
it'll be a roach in here look at that
[ __ ] like we just
i just i can't imagine not being in my
um vernacular
yeah you should take a week you should
do a week of filming with no
try not to say it like just try not to
say it and see how many times you got
ready to say it
and do a chat i mean i think for wow but
it's in my it's in my mind
when i don't say this is going on in my
mind i'm saying it in my mind
you know what's funny is
i missed that [ __ ] you definitely a
long time ago yeah
mike calls me that sometimes yeah and i
love it
i'm like now you feel like you really
really mike and i are really
connected like gary owen said i said he
has gary owen has a black wife he said
that's when he knew he had made it
when she was having sex and she was like
yeah
he said yes finally yeah
[Laughter]
it's just tragic if white people use it
yeah it can't go no other way changes
something into something completely
different you can't say i've
i've heard the most positive way white
people said it and they still got drugs
so i knew
i've heard them say look we're not going
to say we're not going to say that word
we're not going to say [ __ ] in this
class
right there it's like oh oh oh you just
settled
a white person could say you're not this
you're you're you're black people you're
not a [ __ ] and it's like still whoa
so there's just some this is some white
people that just
think that [ __ ] think i'm saying they
don't care who's saying it oh
what a girl they ain't gonna say in
front of cops and [ __ ] anybody
they believe they're [ __ ] yo mike i
was watching a video and two white
people was about to fight
two white dudes and they kept saying
[ __ ] what's up oh [ __ ] what's up
right in the garage and i was looking
around like where's the [ __ ]
they don't stay in front of you they
don't care they
think who they are they're gonna kill
and die for it that's that's how intense
that way and they'll tell you where they
grew up too like that matter of like i
grew up around
i grew around you know rappaport
remember rappaport but he and his tested
deeds kind of did it
no rapaport said when he was a kid he's
not tense like
growing up in in brooklyn he him and his
buddy were like
saying it a lot and and his dad busted
in the room was like whoa whoa what's
going on in here
you know and they didn't understand
because they you know and
usually until he did higher learning
yeah he did the movie and then he
probably got it
better understanding of it
[ __ ] man um what are your thoughts on
death
man are you a god-fearing man i say so
i say i mean religious spiritual uh a
little bit of a little bit of both of
that man cause god
i feel like i make a lot of mistakes and
i talk to god on my own
i don't ever know i don't ever i don't
even know somebody's relationship with
god like i could be holding hands in a
prayer circle
and when we let go i say god oh no no no
[ __ ]
let me talk to you about myself they
could be lying let me tell you what i
need
that's what i need and i i pray for
things and sometimes like today was a
good day because i was uh
a good example i was looking for a green
jacket and i always ask god for stuff
like
my bag be coming out like off the plane
i'm like god i hope my bag is here
you're like god i hope i land safe so i
got ready to say god with my green
jacket i said nah i didn't actually
i didn't ask the [ __ ] for too much
already let me not ask them about this
green jacket because this might
be a lottery it might be my last ask
so i'll say but i do believe
uh i got in trouble a long time ago
cause i was talking about the bible and
i was saying i don't know who really
wrote it so i
and someone said um it's not about you
speaking about the bible about as far as
god goes but as far as
what drives a lot of people what a lot
of people believe in so don't speak
badly of it because it does inspire
and you don't want to talk about the
things that inspire people but between
just me and god i feel like there's no
way i would have
gotten to if it wasn't somebody looking
out i'd have been in too many messed up
situations
that somebody had even if god had an
assistant down here
just looking out i've been in too many
situations where i was supposed to be
somewhere else or doing something
different
you know and so yeah i'll say i'll say
that man
i gotta i gotta believe i would why
don't you think um why do you think um
we ask a lot from god all the time what
do we ever what do you think we're
willing to give
to god because i'm so selfish i don't
think i'm really gay i say that too i
say i don't think
or the things we thank him for it is
sometimes
thanking him for something like god
thank god the police ain't pulling me
over with these guns in my car
i think he should thank you don't really
i need to understand why do i think god
should thank me why do you think he
should thank you
why don't you think you should thank
somebody somebody else or something
that why should he think why should he
what do you wouldn't like
oh cause i thank god why should watch
you think you're right that's a good
question
um i think
okay i think god ultimately looks at who
your true spirit is and the position you
got put in
i don't think he places you in those
positions i think
when you it's like when you land here
you're all landing in the position
you're in
and your choice to be angelic in the
moments that you know are
serious god like i have this thing where
if i see a homeless person
i get a feeling if they're and i'm not
saying i'm psychic
i get a feeling that truly won some in
life and
truly homeless and that person i helped
that i could feel the other
person really doesn't want anything why
is your concern he doesn't want anything
or not
maybe he doesn't want anything [ __ ] he
doesn't want it but he needs to be fed
no no you look at it from that person
because my mom did dope most of my life
and i've watched people need to be fed
narcotics i watch people need to be fed
things they didn't need i i've i've made
these choices before as a young man
growing up
i'm known when i needed to be fed and
what i was willing to sacrifice because
some people i'm willing to give
that food too maybe that's what it is
maybe i know who to throw the ball to me
i know who
who needs this alley-oop in these
moments or maybe i'm not gonna not feed
the one we're talking about but i'll get
back to him but there's a line with
everything we do mr tyson
there's a line we're in and we don't
even know why we're in that line
and you step out of the line for a
second somebody moves up but i do that
with everything i do there's comedians
who i truly help i see i see it in them
they cannot be funnier than the guy
who wants to go on stage but it's a
spirit in them and i
feel it i've always felt like this so
you decide who needs to be helped or not
and no but who's needs to be held by me
yeah really who needs to be held by me
because we all decide that
no i don't know i think that whoever
needs to be helping don't have no
objective there's just
no feeling that you should be helped i
don't know but you i don't think about
their life i'm not in person much
involved with them
but you're going you just but you just
said that earlier today not to say that
you're being contradicted but early
you're talking about
the roth child and the other person yeah
so let's speak of the roth children
yes i'm putting my life and my i'm the
bank at that moment i'm making a
decision to invest
in that person's situation for the
moment because i've been in
dire situations i've called people when
i needed things and i know why they
didn't help me
i have to be accepting on the other side
also i've seen people get things that i
thought i should have gotten
and not been envious because i've never
been my biggest compliment to someone is
always i'm jealous
because i'm not afraid of that that
thing that people say oh you're just
jealous i'm not afraid to say
i'm jealous so i'ma work hard as is the
rest of the sentence so i want
to when when i decide to be that person
delivering what i'm giving to someone
whether it be time or conversation
i can't talk to i talk to somebody i
might talk to somebody
who gonna go talk to 30 people rather
than talk to one person
who feels selfish and not gonna go tell
nobody the system
to to better everybody else i want to
talk to somebody when i die tomorrow
when they share the information they're
gonna share to people that know that
life is not forever i wanna tell to
somebody who like i'm gonna keep this to
myself
so i don't have to always be the
financial help it could be any kind of
any kind of help but i've my like i said
my mother did dope and i've consistently
tried to
pretty much that's just like what we
were talking about with the rothschild
just since you didn't go by this rule
you canceled out
and i canceled out but in my mind you
said why should god thank me that's
where we started from in my mind
i feel like i have a great i've been a
great judge character and this is from
selling dope all the way to jokes i'll
be honest i've been a great judge a
character
i don't believe every police is a [ __ ]
up person i like to i like to
read the people and the person i don't
believe every
i i don't believe everything that i'll
hear a politician say something to sound
[ __ ] up to everybody because we're
looking for the [ __ ] up in it and i'll
go this
i get i want to take i'm sorry for being
so
i like to take my life and people around
me everything is like groceries with me
everything
i'm i'm a good friend like i'm a
different kind of friend like i'm not a
pick you up from the airport friend but
i'm a friend to send you a car
uh i don't i don't mix my groceries up
like if i know you're a freezer [ __ ]
i'm not gonna put you in a fresh produce
out because
we do that a lot with people we say so
you wow
somebody expects so much of you just
because you're you know mike tyson
and they're trying to put you on the
isle that you're not in that's not your
aisle so if they love you and [ __ ] with
you and are you in
they'll never be disappointed by what
they expected of you
so i put i treat everything like
groceries in food
i'll take the most [ __ ] up things like
a politician say i'll take the nutrients
of what he said
and [ __ ] out the rest yeah like i feel
like trump is the kind of guy he's like
yo
don't step in my yard unless you're
cutting it you know unless you bring
something but
there's certain things that he's done
that got him to the position yet i want
to know what those things are the
positive things are
that whatever they were positive sneaky
whatever got whatever the good
whatever it is and then the other [ __ ]
yeah we he
the city be saying be [ __ ] up but what
got him there and how could we get a
black person to somebody who cares about
us and power there with that same money
that same thing the same thing to try to
figure out a way to keep us
all here who care about immigrants care
about this care about that so i say
i just treat it like food everything's
like grocery so i'm not i'm not saying
that
that's great that's what you're saying
is what everybody want to find out we
want to find out how come the poor man
is [ __ ] blessed and how come the
[ __ ] rich man is cursed
people wouldn't know that that's just
what basically you say why is that what
what
we know right now about mr trump is that
the light is on him now and when the
light is on you know can stop you
you could say [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you america [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and how he is and nothing can stop you
life doesn't last forever but when it
lasts it's unstoppable
you know and we don't want to believe
that he has the light because some of us
have
such distinct taste for him how could he
get the light and not me i'm more
i i'm more loving than him i'm more
responsible than him i have more class
than him
i take care of people more than i i'm
just so much better than all around and
he is why did he get the light
right so so that's more so what we were
just saying collectively you and me
kinda that that when i do
deliver whatever bit of a little bit try
to be a glimmer like or a glimpse of
life for somebody
my decision-making that got me here no
one's ever said oh he gave him money
didn't give me money or
nephews and nieces like when my nephew's
grades went good and one was good i gave
them both the same money
i said because this is not dictating how
you're doing in school
because i remember i wasn't that good in
school took me five years out of high
school anybody out there know that
i was smarter on another level i wasn't
smart with
every day i said i'm gonna have these
people that are in this school
who are smarter than me who talking [ __ ]
i'm gonna get them all jobs
working for me and not in a way to say
now you work for me never done that i'ma
get you a job because you're good at
what you do
and that's what i'm up that's what the
energy i want to give out
comedians talk [ __ ] about me people
saying i was being an [ __ ] and i was
never nice what everyone say don't know
my
my mind state was i was being a
businessman first when i try to say that
to them it bores the average comedian
you want to be i want to i want to
control everything i want to be
well hey take it easy
what happened to why are you so and why
are you so intense
i have no idea you want control why do
you want power did somebody hurt your
feelings a long time ago no
i just watch people's feelings get hurt
i like when doors are open
and um if only reason the door should be
closed is because we locked it ourselves
i liked doors and i like making doors
and building doors
yeah i like people saying i like i like
when a young lady tweets
i'm taking my last 300 hours to take
some homes people to the
i want her to be like i want to get her
a place i want to get her you know what
i'm saying i like
i'll take my last money if i believe in
what
if you had him it's just always been
like me i tell people just
all the time well i'm helping you with
money because i've reached out to people
and nobody [ __ ] helped me i remember
the moments but i'm not mad at the
people that did it
and they had the money i watched them by
[ __ ] watch for a [ __ ] and
do this and then i'm like yo well people
owe me money and they went did other
things before they got back to me
who whoever's in the position of power
at that moment to make the best decision
should have that power
well i'm gonna hold on to the water and
i'm on fire
if you out the fire i'm gonna give you
the water so you can pour it on me or go
oh keep moving forward
we don't ever treat none about we rarely
treat our hustles like a baton nobody
ever passes it forward
everybody never understands the relay
race and they could come back to you
again nobody so
i think i always i want that i want that
power to be able to distribute
and come back and people understand and
that's what a good or bad i love
barter system they'll tell you i'm not a
fight
anything you see me [ __ ] looking like
i'm shining this [ __ ] was free or i had
to make a decision
when they was doing hip-hop squares and
saying give me back give me four shirts
or give me the watch and i was like let
me get the watch because the watcher put
you in the room
with the situations to be able to have a
better conversation to get more watches
for more people
you know what i mean so that's that's
what i want to be that's
my passion you're pretty much saying
that um you did this yourself no one
helped you people help nobody people
help me with conversation but let nobody
get people help me with conversation but
no one's ever given me nothing and i
didn't give back like four or five times
i had to
you can't expect to get anything back
you get it how would you give it
sir i've said this a minute every time i
give money to somebody like i'm giving
it to you they said the best way to get
rid of people is a loan of money
i'm saying that's an another and another
light of it believing that too but like
right now like i'm
i'm like what you're doing right now
you're taking your this into your time
it's in your moment we on tyson ranch
and it's all your [ __ ] like i want my
[ __ ]
and i i don't and i i don't want to have
to i don't want to have you
you you've been through whatever you've
been through to get here i don't know it
ends and i
only know what i grew up watching and
what parts i loved and how you always my
champ
but i don't want to fight the way you
fought sir i don't want to take a rib
shot i don't want to get
not i want and i still want to figure a
way where everybody
can can get to i still want this hey
check this out right this is
interesting you say that you don't want
these rips you're going to get it to get
this you're gonna get it
i want my knocked down to be different
i'm saying no i'm saying you know to get
what you want in life yeah you're gonna
get those shots you're gonna get hit
you're gonna get knocked down you get
the feel of it
no i've been hit but i'm talking about
the way you hit people i don't want to
get
no no you're not getting this i know
what you mean sir type let me
get it you're going to get cause this
doesn't come without a price
right none of this stuff all i'm saying
all but all the all the things i go
through and all things i've been through
i'm saying ultimately this is what i i'm
politely saying sir i i want to get to
this point
but you're employing people
people happy to go to work
comfortability
and to know that your name is on
something that you can
leave that people people cared about
what you did rather than just stepping
on your name
on the hollywood square and say who is
this i've i've walked up and down that
street
and there's so many stars i go what did
this person do like
and what was the other side because it's
that's why we live in the day
information you find out why you're
looking at him on your phone
boom yeah what he did
yeah man you know what i beat up no
really you do that's what i would like
boom that's what i look at because
information is just constantly
downloading information
yeah i want to be the information giver
i mean i can't i can't explain it man i
want to event like this they want to
invent something small to get that
everybody needs
imagine you with the giver of
information imagine that you can handle
that
no really you think you said something
really intense can you handle that give
my information
no no you you you're the leader of
information be the giver
of course you can love giving
information really i love being
i love looking at the maze and making it
amazement who created god
that's not in the google we can't google
that no who created god
who cares the thought of god no no god
no it's the thought of god
no this god has no thought no it would
be who created the thought of god
because somebody had to god gave you
right thought
so so right so when you got here god
gave your thoughts so you have the
thought of god first
no that's not the clue before the
presence i don't have the thought of god
when i first opened my eyes
when i first opened my eyes i want to
know what the [ __ ] is going on oh i'll
be like thank god i'm out
of my father's hospitals and whatever
else the first bed i've been whatever it
is i remember
but i don't have no concept but i'm
never gonna say who would create a god
that's something come on
no but you you're the master you're the
giver but even that information not in
here
excuse me even that information on your
phone you can't google that
you can't god google that try it let's
see
no because god comply oh you're checking
me out what you want to know now
mike it's wednesday i'm playing the
lottery man nah god gave god gave you
that mind hey you think you want to know
something figure me out
figure why figure why i put you in this
plan and figure why i gave you a purpose
think of the purpose that i gave you
figure it out sometimes you outside
sometimes people leak outside of the
purpose like you said but god also gave
us the minds to make decisions
and the mistakes
see i was listening as you gave me
information earlier i'm taking oh listen
you know what this class will be talking
to you
professor tyson yes yeah everything but
look everything never happened to all
the people you drove by and cause who
the [ __ ] is it what's my purpose to even
know this but what's my purpose
why did i beep at that girl why did i
even meet this guy
well i know i beat that the girl how did
i how did i get her as my publicist
you know i mean how did that happen how
did i get the agent how did i get here
how did i get around here with enticing
them and doing that
this podcast how did this first start
how did i get the [ __ ] desire to be
on that [ __ ] mic that first day
yesterday to be a comedian
where did that come from you're right
that feeling i i want people to look at
me and see me
this is just way too but even if i
wasn't seen i still want to be
part of comedy or some kind of way no
but it's just that thought of this like
you said it's a thought
it's the thought what gave you the
thought of the courage nobody would have
that [ __ ] courage
this is where i belong god put this in
my mind this is where i belong i'm
walking up
and you can't pay me to walk to a mic
and for nothing you have you
entertaining right now off the coast
right off the back
no i'm not doing that [ __ ] you crazy i
think you can do it you already do it
you're doing and doing it no but i
wouldn't do it i'm not ready right right
right now do it right now right now
you're
what [ __ ] no well we kind of do that no
i'm talking about me going on stage
doing my one-man show right now mikey
get out the [ __ ]
get out the seat take off the headphones
do it right now
no yeah don't worry hell no
it's hard well i know it might get
intense i started sweating you start
asking me about god
a couple of intense dudes in here
because of the trip because sometimes
you think about god and you say that
that's the womb
you wake up in the middle of the
lightning night and you say wow
um what 53 i said no way i'm gonna say
53 more years so what happens after that
do i do my eyes closed when i die do i
wake up from a dream
what happened i can't imagine this
energy i got just blacking out not
existing no more so where does it go
um you know
we'll find out one day one day god will
show you when you get there it has to be
magnificent because life is magnificent
you know i could like how could how
could life be magnificent and death be
bad
how could god want to create you and
make your life miserable for dying
that'd be dumb
my whole thing i just want okay now okay
now since we're talking deep i
i'd rather die regularly though you know
what i mean because you never know if
after you die you have to come back
looking like you went you know i don't
want to think about it i want to be
decapitated i'll come back i gotta hold
my head a decapitated [ __ ]
walking the streets of riding a horse
have we
zombies excuse me yeah i love zombies
yeah definitely zombies i believe
zombies i believe that's real
could come back yeah graveyards are
getting full they are among us already
um well what's what i think is also
an interesting uh tie-in is you're in a
show
called snowfall mm-hmm oh that's a good
chance
we had rick ross on the pod i think so
that was with uh what john singleton so
i think they've had conversations too
so did they not did he not say that uh
he said that snowfall was based on his
story
i don't know okay did he say it happily
um
he's he's got some straightening out to
do
like for instance the rapper rick ross
he feels like he's paraded around
as an ex-drug dealer the freeway rick
ross
and is unwilling to relinquish his name
and all that [ __ ] so he's alright we'll
let the name go but i think that anybody
should pay if
you start rapping and your name mike
tyson you got to pay high
you know that's what yeah i think that's
just fair yeah i like fair
that's another thing too i like i like
what's right if you know what's right
and i know that when he first came out
though i just like i liked the boss song
yeah i didn't i had no idea that that
was yeah i know
but i'll say uh snowfall is uh john
singleton always had a
thought process of hot you know with the
cocaine game yeah getting here and
everything even though he was
removed himself um he was around the
people and stuff like that and i think
him and rick have had come not in depth
probably
i'm sure they should though yeah because
you know he'll step into him
i know he usually don't want to step
into too many worlds that he don't
do the right understand [ __ ] don't want
to get sued anything
yes for sure it's season two season
three now
season three and tell us about your
character and
and where the show is at right now gotta
publish you making money now how that
[ __ ] [ __ ] feels
you got a nice car and [ __ ] i gotta okay
guy i'm i'm not a car dude so i got the
same car i've had since 2007.
cool cool cool what kind
like houses yeah yeah i like homes i
like um
i like going places you like one of
those guys like to save money i like
spin and [ __ ] i do a little bit of both
how do you do both that's interesting
i do saving i do both by i go and i
perform
and i'll take the money i perform um
with and that's why i invest in my shows
that i do all the time i do like
so i still produce my own comedy shows
how's that coming along
fun really it's my favorite thing to do
but i still and i'll take the money from
the shows
put that up or invest in my show and
i'll take the money from the after party
i get paid and i'll spend that
which kind of counts each other out so i
get paid to party in place and i come to
l.a and pay the party
so it's weird where do you live here
uh chicago but here i'm in hollywood
here too okay cool
nice but yeah my character peaches he uh
he's just a
murderer it's a killer that's
quiet killer that's it i just shoot
people that's
it you ever think about one of the
awards and it's just like for movies and
stuff
i practice yeah nice how does that
practice
how does that i mean you probably get to
bring in a lot of comedy
into that character
is it a really dark character in
practice all the time like for no reason
i practice everything i also practice
being like i used to do two
i practice on the elevator like if the
elevator gonna crash i practice like
let's get out of here i swear to god
crazy dude i do i practice like
i practice because i've been in acting
roles where they tell me you got to act
like you're intense and i'd be like oh
[ __ ] i just did the show on the elevator
and i got it so
yeah i practice everything man i
practice you know practice talking to
the girls practice
the mac and practice that's
awesome so you like acting as well yeah
it's it's cool man it's just to step
outside yourself
you know especially you know like
getting to do things like what i did on
empire and that one just
shoot them up like like 21 jump street
yeah shooting guns and
just [ __ ] him should i look weird doing
it what the [ __ ] do you really do
no you look good though yeah i think um
i got a couple i had a couple of movies
coming out like that i never think about
that i think about producers
yeah but i think more so of producing
the film that i'm in so i can have more
you're a big picture guy yeah you like
the i like what jelly like
that's why i came up i like that what he
wanted to do you want your story to get
out you know what i mean you want to be
told correctly
not like telling other people's story
correctly if um
when your movie coming out i don't know
is jamie still playing you it's supposed
to be that way
i wouldn't want nobody else you're the
only [ __ ] that could do it
i mean i'm gonna say that i'm gonna say
that i was the kind when i was a young
kid and i was
fighting this guy i was so egomaniac i
wanted to be always in the front i
didn't give a [ __ ] about backing who's
making more money this is
me [ __ ] look at me as my
when i was like 2018 that was just my
mentality
i just never was nobody as a kid i just
wanted to be somebody when everybody
just
see me and [ __ ] i think you achieved
that yeah very much so
people definitely see people can't unsee
you realize that yeah
the comparisons is the thing that i
crack up all the time like
it'd be two little bitty boxes and
they'd be like he's like the mice i'm
like getting the [ __ ] out of here
yeah yeah you ever seen them fight you
know just for no reason
and you can watch them a hundred times
for no reason i just go to youtube and
be like god
damn like it changed your day man you be
like look at the
just the amount of just energy
and then there comes the time of your
life that that's a blur you don't even
think about that number one you're on
this next
journey that doesn't mean anything the
thirst of
you know success and hunger is still
there you wanna you have to move on and
on and on
what am i gonna do after this do banking
now but if i'm still alive this is just
what it is you got that thirsty one you
want to be successful
you want people to see you want people
to know you're the best you're that poor
kid you don't want to ever go back to
the kid
again you don't want your kids to go
back there again my kids think i might
not
they have to think i'm gonna lie
well i've said that a lot of times i
don't know when you're broke again you
say that a lot i said that a lot of
times like damn
broken that's not true but um you're
talking much you don't want to you don't
be able to have any more cash
because there's some of the richest
people in the world and that's
financially and spiritually broke
we all have to fight that you know that
battle within ourselves
yeah that's consistent yeah many times
you wonder
everybody's going to make money but
everybody's not going to have that
spiritual awakening
yeah yeah that's true i always think
about that like you never it's the
moment you wake up you just
you're not happy all the time you're
wondering what's going on what is what's
missing
you know and moments like that i ain't a
lot of the moments to pray that moments
are just not and i don't say i'm not
someone to super spiritual i'm talking
hey god i don't know what i'm feeling
right now but whatever it is help me
just figure it out that's that's me
my prayers be like i don't know what
this feeling is
like i hope everybody okay like it's in
your stomach you're like what what
what needs to be done is that's missing
because it's not the money thing you
know what i mean
i've left casinos and have won big and
still didn't feel
complete so i know you know the feeling
that rest was just that moment
of playing but you still feel like and
i've i've woke up
in a bed with lovely situations and
still didn't feel like
my whole life you know because we don't
understand our concept of self-love yet
you know how could a guy like maybe 20
years 19 years old have all the money in
the world all the girls
all the best lick in the world the best
week the best cocaine the best
everything money combined i'm just still
upside happy and i want to die
why is that because i have no um
perspective of love of self
so every i act out by being the meanest
and nastiest [ __ ] on the planet
because you haven't had that concept of
self-love it's not something that you
easily grasp
i don't know why you know i would say we
love ourselves and we do this you know
that
me loving myself is um going out with a
hot chick or buying a great car
or a house or playing a great suit or
something that was my
aspect of loving myself when i was
younger
that's what i believed loving myself was
not getting any rest not
taking care of myself not you know
eating the proper foods
you know not just just just caring about
me it's meditating
i had no concept of love of self
and so you have to go to that really
dark moment in life to
become humble to [ __ ] before it could
even be allowed to surface true
man yeah well you come in
and everybody's got
chaos in their head you know our parents
the people that
around us are teachers or family you
know the other kids
you know so you come in and you're just
in the midst of chaos and it's just
constant [ __ ] flying
you know people putting each other down
[ __ ] criticizing
judging exactly who you think you owe
them something
uh who and your friends think you owe
them some they were there before you hit
so
just because they were they're present
you owe me something i was just there
you did more for me than i did for you
but i was just there when i went down so
you kind of owe me
don't get no friends like that mr tyson
fortunately wow what that's
a girl i have i have my one friend the
larry
larry's my friend shout out to larry
larry
law dog but other than that i don't
really know you have the larry's only
one friend you must have been a
miserable
no you had no friends man
i really did man i really i can't think
of nobody to die
man i love you i don't i don't know if i
have friends when i was a kid but when
like i'm 10 11 years old 12 i can go any
neighborhood never have to worry about
people bothering me man in fact i would
raw people in any neighborhood i would
go in because that's that [ __ ] dude
that [ __ ] dirty ass mic
they wouldn't know everybody knows i had
i conceptually i mean just a
guy if the concept what a friend is the
people around me but i never was like
like oh it's a group of guys you can
associate me with because i got brothers
and sisters all day long that's that was
i guess that was more like
my big brothers like my friends and
people like that so i never really had
like
i never was in for my mother knew i was
never influenced by [ __ ] i was never
that's why i don't talk against my my
kid's a daughter but i never
had that and no one could ever talk me
into doing [ __ ] i i just
sit and look like well y'all have fun
doing that [ __ ] then i never had a
like a push pressure because my mother
was like terrified of her for one and
drug
addict or not she had this hold on me
that was like
you know she probably the person that
says you know i owe her something
because how she is
every now and then she'll say like she
don't know maybe she'll know she's lying
she's like i remember i told you to get
into comedy i'm like you ain't never
told me
you've never told me ruby renee davis
you've never told me to [ __ ] with no
comedy
but i'll let her say it i'm like mom
remember i told you you're gonna stay
you said
remember i remember when i first named
you i mean when i first said deray i
knew that name was gonna be oh
my you ain't never you never called me
to break it right up at all and then
when i made my name deep my name's
antoine de ray davis when i said i'm
gonna go by d-ray
and whatever it did however the [ __ ]
what i'm supposed to supposed to be now
she'll be like d-ring my side i'm like
yeah oh people it's it's definitely
people like i say older people
that was involved in things that i i
i thought was glorified then you wasn't
a smart
[ __ ] that stayed away from them bad
guys huh yeah i just like the
like i was one of the [ __ ] driving the
corvette when i was like 15 or 16
because the old
the older drug dealer dude trusted me
because he knew i'm going to get [ __ ]
done they knew i was going to get you
interested you're the worker huh i got
[ __ ] done man
that's how i figured i was figuring
interesting i always wanted to figure
stuff out
my older like when i started comedy the
guys who were helping me were like
40 and 50 years old they just was like
they'd rather give it to me the money
they know i'mma
flip it i'd be like like going in the
room saying
hey man this ain't a drug deal i'm gonna
take this ten thousand dollars
give me a week i'm gonna bring you back
fifteen thousand they're like that is
not a drug deal it's a comedy show
[ __ ] are like get the [ __ ] out
now you know if you don't bring back my
money i'm like
i'm a kid i got it but give me 50
and then you get 13 000 you walk in that
[ __ ] shaking like a [ __ ]
and i'm like here um yeah two thousand
but i kept the two and i'm afraid
man i had the moments but i would take
that i was flipping it i was flipping
that
i was i was able to do it wow i could
never sell
drugs drugs just was too slow for me
something
to do so standing on the [ __ ] corner
all day i did i said
i've probably stood on the corner all of
if all the years i've done whatever i
support myself
probably 14 days maybe maybe two weeks
total because i was always like
there's so there's a way around this
[ __ ] with the excitement of standing on
the corner waiting for
nothing nothing but the little boy's
going to get new jays but what's what's
exciting about being the [ __ ]
16 years old with pounds is very
exciting yeah i can see that being
exciting
right he's never gotten i could walk in
a room and know i could walk up
you could put it in my hand i could i
only need it i never had to weigh it i
know if it was right or not i knew it
was bunk
and i knew the little kids who was like
trying to come up and i knew
i could take some bunk weed mix it with
that sugar water throw it in the
microwave
puff up and go sell it real fast stand
there doesn't make sense why would i sit
down and
and sell it all day when i can wait for
you to do it and once you finish
something i just think give me that
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but you wouldn't know
our girl
hang on i know over there come over here
hey we knew those we knew those guys too
we knew those guys that was that was
going to do that too
and they and i was so cool with them
that they'd be like dude
they making rounds today the [ __ ] up out
of here you know like
not like i got it bro cause i had to i
had to other situations too
nobody had girls like nobody had to do
it
he's romanticizing his whole lifestyle
he loved it
i just love the cup i love the cup like
like the nino brown
[ __ ] i like all that like i don't wanna
see people all cracked out there
everything you know my mom like i said
she went through her era with the drugs
so i really rock with that but the other
[ __ ] man like just on some
to see people making money now weed is
[ __ ] hilarious
yeah that the government i'm like you
[ __ ]
i was hiding the [ __ ] out of it wrong
they've been like terrible
for so long about so many drugs that
they still hide from us and tell us
it's bad if we use it we're going to
jail yeah man i'm hurting myself and
you're going to put me in jail
that's what you believe damn you better
put me in jail from hurting myself
i'm going to get locked up for years to
prevent me from hurt hurting myself but
you're locking me up with killers
and murderers and rapists and they're
savages
you know that's because i smoked crap
yeah exactly
thank you mr government uh
what's your feeling on the state of
things the government
trump this new election do you have any
thoughts
i think it slipped away i think people
didn't pay attention in certain
instances i think
we put people in positions of power and
once they get there
you got mad when they was exactly who
they told us they was going to be
trump has been the same guy as far as i
see i i always i never saw him as
i always thought he was funny when he
wanted to be funny like whatever they
did
the acting and home alone in the show
whatever he did the the apprentice i
always thought that was always funny but
i never
looked at him like he gonna sit down
with some [ __ ] and
be okay with it so they parade they put
him in a position of power
they put all this emphasis on what what
popularity is now just like
he was saying everything's tv everything
dis-driven that driven
so he already had the votes and then he
talked that [ __ ]
from the the way a black person talked
about black power and get people to
follow him
he talked that that white [ __ ] and they
was like cool
hell yeah he came out with a white rap
album
with everything that's really the people
wanted to hear
that way they want to hear and it was
like we buying this this right now this
[ __ ] going to go platinum and they went
[ __ ]
bought it even the people that's
uncomfortable with now
got it home and realized it all wasn't
hits
his thought was his reality he made it
holiday
i mean the great thing is the best thing
about trump
is that hopefully he woke up a lot of
people
you know yeah and you say what you gotta
do man you know
that's the best thing that happened
because we were all asleep
you know well we see smidges of it
though we would see like not saying in a
bad way we see like uh
arnold schwarzenegger becoming governor
we've seen pieces of that
that that that kind of not only but not
only the celebrity
but his rhetoric and all the
[ __ ] hate and the [ __ ] that he spews
you know it was like oh this is a man i
don't know i know no i know exactly what
you mean by that but i'm saying as far
as the ability yeah yeah
to win it like remember when again
reagan
running like this in the moments i'm
saying
yeah ronald reagan was that too but i
mean like in them but to see it all
happening the way it did here like it
was a buffoonery for a minute and
here everybody's like i'm [ __ ]
running mm-hmm
and they knew what it was and you don't
you can't take nothing like that for
granted you can't
yeah i never thought you could take [ __ ]
like that for granted there's a lot of
people that couldn't even
grasp that he might win i know i don't
know i sat behind a black dude at a bar
and he was like trump for the win
he said you talking about this about
that and i was looking at the [ __ ] like
what did you see oh he wasn't talking to
me talking to a young lady he's like
trump gonna win he's like and he gonna
do this and do that and i was sitting
there like nah
nah and in my mind i wouldn't believe it
so when i thought when i saw
him on the stage against hillary i was
like
i [ __ ] arrived it's [ __ ] this is
over it was the lunchroom yeah he hit it
with the lunchroom yeah this is over
you can't win the lunchroom again he hit
it with the bladder look at the lady
talking yeah
wow so i'm at home i'm 50 years old
i've been watching [ __ ] make money
i've been watching
i've worked for my son worked for a
black person that's awful
and i'm sitting watching the trump go oh
hell yeah
yeah it's awful everybody get up wife
cousins exist
sister niece get up these people exist
came out of retirement to go vote yeah
they did is just like
what remember that movie where chris
rock ran for president
yeah and he was just with brandy
magazine running for the second right
with chris rogers this but it looks like
chris rock is about to win
all the white people ran down to the
polls
that's what it was it's like we can win
people would c i think it's people that
cared about the climate of
finance uh finances in america whatever
that
didn't particularly [ __ ] with him as a
person
uh-huh just the whole thing man he put
together just
put together a suit man yeah
yeah dude that was that's soup then
maybe important
do you feel you want to be important to
society
i don't know what i'm trying to
understand clearly like influential
by the way you're talking about that
lifestyle and that [ __ ] talk you like
you like that lifestyle like
no wait but do you want to be a leader
in society do you feel you want that
right do you want to
uphold that [ __ ] responsibility of
being a leader
yeah i like that but i need to make the
note that the way that you just asked me
that is the way that they would ask me
in rooms about [ __ ] how you just said
you want to be important that sound like
a mafia i like wait a minute
dude he took a moment
he like you want to be important i'm
like i don't know
maybe right but yes baby
yes mr tyson i would love to be a leader
man
i feel like i'm a leader in the light
skin community
i agree you already are man i'm like not
everybody listen to me but i have a i
have a good time talking to people man
yeah it's funny you tell your kids
you're like yo check this well
you how you gonna say i'm wrong i'm
wrong when i just did
i'm on tour martin i just did 13 000
people listened
to me but you telling me is your father
that's wrong
i just had 13 000 people cheering
standing up because what i'm saying is
funny and obviously right to them in
their mind
and you're telling me that i'm wrong
about telling you about
these [ __ ] you hanging around right
now get out of there it's a good
argument
how are you gonna tell me that [ __ ] you
don't know [ __ ] well dude i think you
should have your own podcast
i feel like no i'm just going to come
just sit on yours all the time
you're saying that now until you start
getting those likes and you see how many
people watching you say holy [ __ ]
i want more and you get addicted to that
you say wow people really care about
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about i don't
care about what i'm talking about
and um you'd be surprised it might not
be as interesting then because i got to
have two people not
smoking weed while i'm in the room oh
you can have this for me to have this
guy cause i be like
that definitely influenced my
conversation a little bit i'm definitely
something
yeah i don't know right now but it's not
bad it's a little longer
take that water dude it's good
it's good [ __ ] won't get you high i
promise
that's a good stigma to have the high
getter the highest can i get it
i get high high high
hi well before we wrap this thing up man
is there anything
you do you want to be a superstar you
want me to do movies you want to do some
big things
i'm [ __ ] put it out there yeah put it
out there i always yeah yeah i've done
those man we've i've done the not the
i've done the move i want to be in a
position where i'm doing my own stuff
i want my company on full custody films
to be just that running its own thing
have my own um
thing like you said it starts with with
things like this i got to
reach out to all platforms and have it
have it done but
yeah i definitely want to be a superstar
but more than that i feel like i'm not
i'm never going to be a superstar if i
don't make somebody as great as i am
like comedically or somebody get it or
everybody understand i want comedians to
have
my biggest goal right now is for us to
have some kind of guild
i've had friends die and had no money
because all they did was stand up and
there's no health plan for just
stand-ups
and [ __ ] to take your joke and put it
on a a podcast you wouldn't even know
it'd be a just ig guy in here just
riffing i don't know
someone never watched it comedian's
guild like something like that or
we don't have a writer's guild for like
when somebody take a joke and they put
it in a movie i just seen
one of my bits on a tv show that's a and
i i posted
back to back and i was like the writer
seen my bit and didn't
it should be something and i'm in the
writer's guild wow i'm going to write
this girl and it says
blatantly but then you got to go prove
it shows but i just want that respect
that comics
whoever wrote like he mentioned richard
pryor is reasons we talk about people
like richard
he was his own person his own jokes his
own things and anything
associated with him is his that's where
the ownership in my mind come from
anything associated with me is mine and
if i make a mistake
because it happens to comedies all the
time they walk past
another comic and don't notice they're
paying attention to
what they just heard if i make a mistake
correct me
say dude that's such and such bit he
started on that day that's what i i need
that
but it's a hard place to get to when
people
you just go up there i've told comedians
new comics they'll do a joke and i'll
say your whole set was funny but this
joke in particular is such and such
they're like
oh really okay see the [ __ ] three
months later still doing it
i i'm i don't know how to explain it
other than like
you know it's like your block it's like
like like the dope game this is my
this my street you know i'm a lot of
people i'm mine old guys like sammy
david they said um
if they had what they had to tell me the
experience they told me they said um
i worked too hard i took myself too
serious i should have had more fun when
i was
when i had that hunger working so hard i
should have been having fun doing it you
know what i mean
yeah worrying about them i'm going to
really just enjoying that
just enjoying it yeah yeah it's just
let's go for the ride
that's the ticket the journey so i'll
say that i definitely have a good time
putting together shows i definitely
love booking comics and i i can't say
i'm not having fun because uh
yeah it's awesome yeah yeah yeah this
one i mean this is
you they didn't get these opportunities
either like i imagine if sammy imagine
if richard pryor could have
said it my god podcast or been beautiful
legendary legendary [ __ ]
man all those guys man they had their
own podcast that would be awesome
yeah my goal is to have a goal damn it
hey it's good to be goalless because
then you're desireless
desire less and that's how big is
that's that's our closest inclination to
the devil
our desire and our ego they thought it
dropped in on you
in buddhism that makes us uncomfortable
we have desire that's why we get happy
we don't have it yet my desire to have
that i don't have it i'm not happy till
i possess that
so that i go to that period of
unhappiness just because however long it
takes me to possess that
and then i possessed it and it just
makes me happy as i thought it would
it's all an illusion in our minds
desires lead to suffering
desirelessness is
how you know when you've reached
enlightenment when you're completely
desireless and
that's the match in a white gown
floating
hair flowing in the
design [ __ ] house to swole jesus
desires
excuse me latte
i [ __ ] love that on that note we're
going to wrap this [ __ ] up
man dude thank you so much you are the
man
thanks thanks you're so awesome that was
really fun
well you're welcome back any time thank
you any kids
like great show hey yeah you got any
girls man and a couple
in california that you really like
because i know when you start getting
family
they come and they look really nice out
there they look different they got
different energy than any girl in the
[ __ ] planet
true learn that from my daddy you find a
girl in los angeles
have a different [ __ ] whole
inclination than any other [ __ ] woman
on the planet yeah the hustlers in them
and
girls from flor um cat los angeles and
chicago there's there's no people like
them they're totally different kind of
species of people
now a little bit of miami too a little
bit of miami got that too no i don't go
to chicago not like this
they're different species chicago love
yeah and different
compared to l.a and chicago for
something else
oh no no chicago got that gangs yeah
chicago got that that
like the women are like like really
bossy and don't
[ __ ] need you at all you're just
really smart i don't need you strong
women
i got it strong you know what i'm saying
la's like
la is all the women from all over the
world that made it in their little
cities
they're like we should all we can all
make it then they get here that's why
you see a
super fine girl working like at a
regular place like chick-fil-a or
something
it's like sheen yeah you're an actress
yeah she's like yeah i'll let you know i
got
my head shots in your bag but uh but all
the beautiful women
they're looking for husbands or trips to
dubai
yeah oh they're not coming back and then
the buyers are gonna purchase them
that's why it's called dubai it's dark
it's a dark road do purchase
a stop on the dark road and with french
i go to dubai french he has a party
right
so i go to dubai and frenchie has the
most beautifulest girls in the world
where he knows all these girls from and
i'm just realizing i was out on the
street the other day looking in the
stores and looking to bicycle i never
saw any people at the [ __ ]
um the counter to check and so nobody
works in the town something where did
all these girls come from where do they
live and it's shipper men
huh yes they have a party they shouldn't
come all over the world just have
parties
crazy there's there's no party girls
there's no stability there
there's no people that live there
there's like great buildings but no one
lives in there
god [ __ ] that life man you know what i
mean all these great the
magnificent city multi-billion dollar
city no one lives in the buildings yes
it was too expensive say leave out of
the big building and go home to their
studio apartment
some new louboutins they offer people
they offer people money to stay like
something lovely they
give them money if they live there and
stuff damn
they make it you know to make it yeah
like they don't have a structure system
that's what i wanted they didn't have a
structure system
infrastructure infrastructure yeah they
don't have the they'll have like going
to the grocery store
judicial system don't normally it's just
i have power this is what you do if he
does that
i'm one guy this is my family if he does
that this is what he does all right
that's all right it's okay
this is what's going to happen we all
come to agreement this is going to
happen
they don't have i don't know
yeah well over there if you're caught
in a room with a girl and she's not your
wife
or walking down the street if you're in
the room with your
first cousin if she's not your wife and
stuff you're in trouble
right yeah like you can be arrested
can you be arrested she's not your wife
you're going to jail
yeah well how do you in dubai yeah yeah
but i don't know
for the locals and i know me and my wife
make sure that we didn't do
have too much um affection and public
affection there's no public affection
wow they do some nasty stuff without
girls that flew to dubai i've heard some
stories over everything
weird clothes oh i've heard some girls
and let things happen to him
yeah [ __ ] that quick check [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
40 grand to let guys do certain things
[ __ ]
40 grand oh i did 40 bucks extremes
extreme models
speaking of 40 grand what happened
oh yeah we did 40 grand we're for weed
smoking
a month a month yes you ain't getting no
clear pictures in here i don't know how
them camera's picking up it's a little
it's the hot box bro
okay you know keep it smoky in here
well thank you again man oh yeah it's
awesome what are you doing next
uh still still a snowball hip-hop
squares on it's still touring man uh
[ __ ] what you want to claim to want to
win under the [ __ ] award
yeah man i'm thinking about yeah yeah
oscar [ __ ] oscar grammy
[ __ ] i think i'm gonna play him in the
movie that
like jamie play you and i'm gonna play
him i can pull that look that's gonna be
a neat trick how was that
that's great it's good hey i'm close i
love it
i love it i love that i get my muscles
up
give me a couple apple boxes growing my
hair out long enough so i can get
cornrows
easy you know what i'm saying not be
culture inappropriation appropriate
appropriation
yes i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm just
saying
right anyway yeah that was my goals man
let's get it it's dope
let's [ __ ] go baby my goal is to make
funny
d ray davis as evan britton
mike tyson yes all right in the house
tyson rancho as well yes
and he's also making tyson ranch sauce
coming soon
i really don't think that's so but tyson
ranch sauce is coming
forever have you tasted the tyson ranch
sauce
do you have any tyson ranch sauce no way
[ __ ] grapefruit
hot sauces are great poupon black people
great poop tabasco
sauce i agree poupons
louisiana tobacco all right everybody
well
well i didn't well i'm gonna do tyson
ranch sauce just gonna see it's gonna be
a picture kind of like yours on there
subscribe to the youtube channel hot
boxers mike tyson check out our website
hot boxing podcast it's gonna be
bad yeah jesus yeah
testified justified until next time
we're out
what
[Music]
[Music]
you